bonsoir nous sommes le 12 février 2015
il est l'heure du journal de la
rédaction sur tv fil 78 au cours de la
prochaine demi heure il sera question et
des habitants d'un quartier de trappes
qui réclame la mise en place d'un
système de vidéosurveillance après deux
réunions infructueuses fructueuse avec
la mairie une pétition circule
actuellement la gauche divisée pour le
scrutin départemental de mars le front
de gauche avec le parti communiste fait
le choix d'europe écologie les verts les
explications sur ce plateau de julien
iborra le secrétaire départemental dans
les yvelines du parti communiste à la
marque bébé cadum vient de fêter les 90
ans de son célèbre concours dans les
onze finalistes figurent et inna ya deux
ans et demi nous étions présents lors de
la cérémonie
dès cette nuit et pour quatre autres
supplémentaires une opération assez
spectaculaire va se dérouler à la gare à
des chantiers à versailles le grutage de
la seconde passerelle d'accès aux quais
le trafic sera totalement interrompue ce
sont près de 200 tonnes qui seront
soulevées la nouvelle passerelle pèsera
mesure à 100 mètres de long sur 10 m de
large la grue qui va permettre cette
main et l'une des plus imposantes en
europe elle pèse jusqu'à 650 tonnes avec
une flèche de 96 mètres il aura fallu
quatre jours pour l'assemblée
construire une passerelle au dessus des
voies ferrées soninké en exploitation
c'est beaucoup plus difficile et donc
l'opération rah soleil qui va se
dérouler sur deux week-ends consécutifs
qui commence vendredi 13 et qui se
terminera le week end après consiste à
gruté en fait une passerelle 200 mètres
de long et 2 200 tonnes au dessus des
lunes paris brest le tour en 55 eur
c'est une vraie prouesse technique on
s'imagine pas mais cette passerelle
métallique et qui est fait thrill très
lourd de pièces massives elle a une
tolérance de pause sur sur les kids les
poteaux de 2 mm c'est à dire qu'on a on
a 24 poteau qui ont été tous alignés en
visée laser et on va venir poser
délicatement avec précision au bon
endroit au bon appui les deux colis et
avant de pouvoir les souder il ya des
mini réglages de planning très
d'horizontalité et donc c'est la
précision ces deux millimètres donc
d'où l'intérêt d'avoir une grue très
précises qui nous permet de travailler
avec beaucoup de finesse vous êtes en
fait une des plus grandes grues
d'europe il y en a que trois en europe
pour faire ce genre d'opération c'est
une entreprise donc franco belge de
l'entreprise dufour avec eulex avec
laquelle la sncf a déjà travaillé cette
grue qui fait 100 m dos et qui pèse 2
650 tonnes alors 100 m dos et un peu le
premier étage la tour eiffel 650 tonnes
c'est un peu 14 wagons de marchandises
voyez elle est arrivée en petits
morceaux elle est arrivée avec 50
camions et poids lourds d'allemagne il a
fallu donc organisés à travers
versailles des convois exceptionnels
des habitants qui réclament un système
de vidéosurveillance c'est dans le
quartier de la boissière attrape la
sphère est ancienne elle date de février
et 2014 malgré deux réunions organisées
en avril et au mois de mai rien ne
semble avoir évolué le point sur cette
situation avec william peel
depuis un an nicolas grau habite à
trappes dans le quartier de la boissière
un quartier réputé sensible le bureau de
tabac avaient fait l'objet de braquages
il y a deux ans en février 2014 ils
lancent une pétition pour la mise en
place de caméras de surveillance devant
les commerces donc là on est on a
dépassé les 300 sièges sur cette semaine
notamment grâce aux réseaux sociaux les
gens sont mobilisés des habitants des
îles immédiatement des habitants toute
la france donc je pense à un ras-le-bol
des trappistes mais également des
français en général sur la sécurité
constante nos deux trappes et de la
france en général une pétition adressée
au maire également soutenue par othman
das roux membre de l'opposition à
trappes donc c'est un sujet qui
malheureusement traîne depuis un petit
moment sans que l'on comprenne bien ce
que la municipalité souhaite faire sur
ce sujet si une réponse technique est
possible puisque si j'ai bien compris
les commerçants souhaitent mettre en
place un dispositif de vidéosurveillance
moi j'y suis favorable j'avais indiqué
déjà en 2013 de son côté la mairie dans
un communiqué rappelle que le centre
commercial est une propriété privée pour
installer des caméras sur des fonds
publics la ville souligne qu'il faudrait
utiliser les mâts d'éclairage du
boulevard ce qu'a refusé la casse qui
qui en est le gestionnaire la solution
pour la municipalité les commerçants
doivent mettre en place leur propre
système de vidéosurveillance un courrier
dans ce sens a été adressé à nicolas
grau en début de semaine à trappes
toujours les locaux d'emmaüs ont changé
d'emplacement il se trouve dorénavant
face à pôle emploi ce déménagement va
permettre un meilleur accueil comme nous
l'expliquent catherine jonathan
avec la valise yeux vous la gardez les
bénévoles d'emmaüs et les clients ont
déjà pris leurs marques dans la nouvelle
boutique ouverte dans la zac du buisson
de la coudre des locaux qui remplacent
ceux situés dans le centre ville de
trappes et qui ont été présentés dans le
cadre de l'aménagement du plateau urbain
de la nationale 10 nous avons choisi un
local
commercial c'est à dire moderne avec
beaucoup d espaces adaptés à la
clientèle à l'accès est pour l'instant
nous en sommes ravis
la surface de vente est dorénavant de
1000 mètres carrés trois boutiques en
rez-de-chaussée pour les vêtements le
bric à brac et les livres un espace est
réservé aux meubles et aux produits
d'électroménager le magasin ouvert ce
samedi en une journée près de 400
personnes sont venues voir les nouveaux
locaux beaucoup plus grand club qui
avait avant la crise trouver dans le
centre ville d'aba et tout était
beaucoup serré là c'est beaucoup mieux
comme il vient souvent parce que cherche
des anciens de fauteuils pour les
retaper c'est plus facile et puis on n'a
plus de fonds beaucoup de gens nous
amènent leurs cartons la vêtements
beaucoup beaucoup de doha tous les jours
nous sommes ouverts tous les jours pour
les dons comme christiane la communauté
de trappes compte une petite trentaine
de bénévoles pour s'occuper du magasin
en dehors de ces bénévoles la communauté
accueilli auparavant des compagnons ils
ont été jusqu'à 17 à l'année dernière
mais aujourd'hui des pavillons qui les
accueillaient vont être rasées et faute
de locaux pour les recevoir ils ne sont
plus que deux aujourd'hui la communauté
a été un petit peu éparpillés à partir
du mois de juin pour essayer de les
recaser un petit peu partout dont
certains avec des droits à la retraite
et puis d'autres qui sont repartis dans
d'autres communautés
la communauté emmaüs négocie
actuellement avec la mairie de trappes
pour retrouver une solution
d'hébergement des compagnons dans des
foyers sociaux
et puis à trappes enfin trois frères
âgés de 25 à 30 ans sont soupçonnés par
la police judiciaire d'avoir animé un
trafic local de cocaîne une affaire qui
a permis la saisie de 40 kg de cette
drogue sur le tarmac de l'aéroport de
roissy l'invité de ce soir julie bora
bonsoir vous êtes le responsable
départemental du parti communiste il va
être question à présent de politiques
plus particulièrement des élections
départementales la stratégie pour vous
c'est de ne pas s'allier avec le parti
socialiste mais plutôt dans le cadre du
front de gauche de se rapprocher
d'europe écologie les verts pourquoi
tout simplement alors c'est pas
exactement ça pour être plus précis nous
on souhaite le rassemblement le plus
large possible de la gauche mais sur des
contenus qui sont clairement anti
austérité en rupture avec les politiques
qui sont menées aujourd'hui on parlera
de gouvernance parti socialiste de fait
ça revient à ça même s'ils y compris on
renonce pas à voir des socialistes qui
nous rejoignent qui viennent avec nous
sur des initiatives ou dans des
élections c'est possible aussi dans
certains endroits ponctuellement ce sera
celle d'un gars dans ces cas-là par
rapport au parti socialiste et la ligne
affiche et oui je sais pas ce que veut
dire exactement le terme et frondeur je
vois qu'il y en a qui se reconnaissent
plus ou moins dans cette définition en
tout cas ceux qui refusent la politique
aujourd'hui d'austérité qui est menée en
france avec les conséquences dramatiques
on connaître pour la pour la population
donc nous on veut le rassemblement le
plus large de la gauche il effectivement
et particulièrement sur 50 ans à se
déclinent plutôt sur des rassemblement
avec europe écologie qu'ils se situent
eux est vraiment dans cette rupture
vis-à-vis de l'austérité alors quels
sont les points justement de
rapprochement avec ce qui est affiché
par europe écologie les verts sur quoi
vous vous êtes mis d'accord est ce qu il
a aussi fallu faire des concessions pour
vous non parce qu'on n'y va chacun avec
notre identité propre ça veut dire c'est
pas en fusillade ont créé un nouveau
parti on y va avec nos différences mais
avec ce qui nous rassemble et on a
estimé que ce qui nous rassemble est
plus fort que ce qui nous sépare est
donc évidemment on a des points d accra
avec europe écologie on a même des
points d accord entre communistes de
temps en temps donc donc ça viendra tout
à l'heure que ça c'est donc ça ça arrive
mais on est d'accord sur le fait que la
politique qui est menée aujourd'hui en
france par un gouvernement
malheureusement socialiste mais c'est
une politique de casse des services
publics de restriction des moyens des
collectivités locales là on part dans
une élection pour une collectivité
locale justement et donc ça ça nous
rapproche et c'est ça qui est
fondamental aujourd'hui la cassure est
trop forte avec le parti socialiste
aujourd'hui j'espère pas j'espère qu'il
sera possible un jour de retravailler
sur un rassemblement de gauche mais il
faudra que le les dirigeants nationaux
du parti socialiste et notamment et
particulièrement le gouvernement marque
une rupture par rapport aux politiques
qui sont mis au jour d'hui qui sont pas
dignes d'un gouvernement de gauche mais
là à l'échelle locale en tout cas quels
sont les rapports avec le parti
socialiste pour le front de gauche pour
le parti communiste sk des échanges est
ce que vous avez ne serait-ce que
discuter vous vous êtes mis autour de la
table à monsieur temps départementale
bien sûr on a discuté des réunions avec
europe ecologie les verts le parti
socialiste y compris d'autres partis
comme le parti de gauche et d'autres et
on a vu que c'était pas que ce n'était
pas possible y compris parce que des
fois les propositions n'existait même
pas parce que dans tel ou tel endroit le
parti socialiste ou d'autres avaient
décidé de partir tout seul et que voilà
donc il y avait pas une une volonté de
toute façon ni de la part du parti
socialiste ni de la part d' écologie les
verts ni de la part du parti communiste
de partir ensemble partout c'était
canton par canton qu'est ce qui était
possible qu'est ce qui n'était pas
possible on voit d'ailleurs qu'il ya des
endroits dans le département c'est moins
le cas par ici où l'alliance avec europe
ecologie les verts n'a pas été possible
pour diverses raisons voilà c'est comme
ça nous on a vraiment travailler
localement canton par canton à partir
des réalités locales voir ce qui était
possible et pas possible de faire
ensemble ça veut dire ensuite que le
programme qui sera affichée sera propre
à chaque canton où vous êtes mis
d'accord sur une stratégie globale pour
ce département des yvelines comme je
vous dis il ya des grosses les arrêts de
jeu qu'on partage donc ils sont vrais
dans tous les cantons où on est présent
ensemble même si là où on ne part pas
forcément ensemble et on est d'accord je
vous disais mais principalement sur
l'arrêt du massacre quoi arrêter la
casse des collectivités certains traits
communs à l'échelle du département à
l'échelle du département on voit qu'on a
un département qui est très riche un des
plus riches de france avec un budget de
un milliard un milliard deux je crois
annuel en 2014 en tout cas avec 300
millions d'euros dé vous dédié à
l'investissement donc on voit que c'est
des budgets colossaux et pourtant que la
politique la politique menée par le
conseil général aujourd'hui c'est une
politique a minima on est vraiment à
minima de tous que ce soit sur les aides
sociales sur
sur les réfections de routes etc etc on
le voit alors que quand on vois je vais
prendre l'exemple d'un autre département
le valent bien tard ne pas le citer
qu'un département la direction
communiste on voit les différences
flagrantes avec un département qui a
moins de moyens on nous disait tout à
l'heure j'avais eu une discussion avec
avec un ami qui me disait dans le
val-de-marne et a72 crèches
départementales pour un budget qui est
moindre dans les yvelines la dernière
crèches départementales elle a fermé
l'année dernière donc on voit qu'il ya
possibilité de voir une vraie politique
au service des populations pour réduire
les inégalités dans un département qui
est marqué par de très très fortes
inégalités avec des villes excessivement
pauvres comme trappe
la verrière et des villes beaucoup
beaucoup plus riches saint germain en
laye versailles pour pour pas les citer
donc voilà réduire les inégalités savoir
une politique sociale qui est ambitieuse
et qui aujourd'hui n'est pas celle qui
est menée par là par la direction de
droite en place aujourd'hui au conseil
général et vous ne vous retrouvez pas
dans ce qui est proposé par le parti
socialiste et c'est pour ça donc il n'y
aura pas d'alliance avec les socialistes
malgré tout la gauche lors est elle
mieux fait de partir rassemblés pour ce
scrutin voici vos réponses et notre
question du jour je pense que c'est
préférable pour elle compte tenu du
contexte politique si elles veulent
avoir une chance de remporter un certain
nombre de sièges
c'est ce qu'on entend disons sur les
dans les médias aujourd'hui pour moi je
pense que ils doivent se rassembler oui
parce que les courants politiques
doivent doivent être unis pour avoir une
certaine portée pouvoir avoir de
l'importance après s'ils ont vraiment
des raisons de se diviser vos qui se
divisent officiellement et qui fasse
vraiment quelque chose de clair et net
quoi effectivement ils devaient se
rassembler vos par rapport à l'agresser
à la à l'espagne quoi avoir le même
sursaut finalement et
mais bon je pense pas que bien que je
sois élu
que ce soit des miracles pour le monde
le depor qu'elle est de l'ingénieur à
l'ouvrier tu vois des gamins quoi je
trouve que le lâche on est dans une
situation quand même grave et
ça va mal à l'extérieur l'intérieur
socialement et financièrement
économiquement que tout va bien on a
besoin d'eux de resserrer les rangs mais
ça ne se fera pas je suis très
pessimiste on a besoin de resserrer les
rangs c'est ce qu'on a pu entendre vous
n'avez pas peur que ce soit très
préjudiciable à la gauche dans son
ensemble pas uniquement au parti
communiste mais au front de gauche
europe écologie les verts aux
socialistes aussi cette division et ce
manque d'entente autour d'un tel scrutin
si bien sûr moi je encore une fois je
regrette j'ai commencé en disant qu'on
était pour un rassemblement de la gauche
c'est pas pour des rassemblements le
département pierre bédier le président
sortant veut faire le grand chelem c'est
ce qu'il a annoncé il ya deux des poids
lourds qui se présentent à droite
notamment des mères qui se présente le
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint-quentin aussi
serait sera candidat n'avait pas peur de
ne pas partir unie c'est encore une fois
le rassemblement oui mais qu'est ce que
ça voulait c'est-à-dire pas n'importe
quel prix ça veut dire sur des contenus
clairement à gauche du contenu qui
changent la vie des gens si c'est être
élu pour être élu même on va faire
alliance jusqu'au modem ou quoi même il
ya des gens de l'ump qui sont sympas
peut-être là que des gens de l'ump on
peut faire l'alliance et non pas
n'importe quel prix pas sur des contenus
politiques de gauche fort il y avait un
nouveau une des personnes que vous
interrogez qui parlait de syriza et de
plus et de podemos en espagne c'est
intéressant ce qui se passe là bas on
voit qu'on a une social démocratie qui à
force de mener des politiques beaucoup
plus vigoureuse eu envie de dire que
celles qui ont lieu en france avec des
conséquences plus dramatiques même si on
en prend malheureusement le chemin on
voit qu une social démocratie qui s'est
effondré c'est une gauche qui a été
porteuse de contenus très fort de
comptes riveraine transformateurs en
rupture avec les politiques libérales
qui sont menées c'est cette gauche là
qui arrive à porter au pouvoir et qui
dès son élection en tout cas en grèce
mais des politiques en place sera
possible de charges france d'arriver à
ce résultat là j'aime pas les
comparaisons parce que c'est des pays
très différents des réalités extrêmement
différentes des histoires politiques
très différentes hausses il en rêvait en
tout cas j'en rêve ce serait bien ouais
je vais pas vous inscrire non non on
préfère rester à 5% non évidemment que
évidemment qu'un destin la syriza ça
nous intéresse mais ça c'est du travail
et surtout c'est des situations très
différentes et j'aimerais pas en arriver
à la situation de la grèce pour en
arriver là on va juste faire une
parenthèse on va évoquer le canton de
trappes forcément nous avons eu hier en
ligne le musée il se présente au nom du
front de gauche europe ecologie les
verts c'est assez particulier parce que
le maire de la verrière qui est
communiste du parti communiste français
se présente il fait alliance avec la
gauche le parti socialiste en tout cas
divers-gauche annie-marie la
représentante sur le canton sortante
mais vous ne soutenez pas vous présenter
malgré tout un candidat face à lui on
présente pas malgré tout un candidat
face à lui on est une organisation
démocratique le parti communiste
français qui a eu un vote de tous ses
adhérents qui ont décidé que compte tenu
des réalités locales y compris compte
tenu de du bilan de jal et de marie en
tant que certaines de ses prises de
position il n'était pas possible de ceux
de se rassembler avec les socialistes
d'ailleurs nos amis d'europe écologie
les verts ont pris exactement la même
décision donc nous avons décidé de
joindre nos forces pour présenter quatre
candidatures à l'arrachage comme c'est
son droit le plus strict devenu
démocratie lui n'était pas d'accord avec
avec cette prise de position qu'il a
décidé de prendre de prendre ses
responsabilités de d'être candidat
malgré tout il n'est pas contre nous et
pas plus que nous sommes contre lui on
est contre la droite contre l'extrême
droite on a juste pris des positions
différentes je n'ai pas mené campagne
contre la candidature non socialiste va
de l'imaginaire qui reste malgré tout du
parti communiste mais campagne contre la
droite et l'extrême droite on va pas on
parlait de division de la gauche tout à
l'heure ça commence par rassembler le
plus grand nombre de voix possible pour
la gauche au premier tour et ensuite que
ces voix se rassemblent sur la
candidature la mieux placée au deuxième
tour mais encore une fois dans les
comptes la droite et l'extrême droite
voilà il se trouve qu'on a un point de
désaccord ça arrive dans les familles on
s'engueule on sait que pas drammen
justement juste propos pour conclure sur
cette situation-là vis-à-vis d'allinges
âge vous êtes le responsable département
du parti communiste il est exclu il est
mis en parenthèse en congé comment ça
sera non pas du tout il n'est pas exclu
une union entre parenthèses il reste
communiste il n'a pas perdu son âme de
communistes ou d'un coup ça reste un
très bon maire en mer dont on est fier
encore une fois on n'est pas d'accord la
ponctuent helmand il pourra pas
s'exprimer au nom du parti communiste
évidemment pendant cette campagne mais
puisqu'il en aval investiture officielle
forcément d'exactement mais ça n'ira pas
plus loin que ça il n'y a pas de
problème avec à l'agent n'est juste pas
d'accord car il est juste pour conclure
sur ces départementale pour le parti
communiste le front de gauche il y aura
des candidats présents partout vous avez
vous présenté partout sur tous les
cantons les 21 dans quasiment tous les
cantons oui là-bas c'est le dépôt des
candidatures on n'est jamais arrivé on
n'est jamais à l'abri à l'abri d'une
mauvaise surprise mais dans quasiment
tous les cantons laddh me semble qu'on a
dû en déposé 18 sur les sur les 21
quelque chose comme ça donc donc presque
partout et peut-être une question
subsidiaire pour pour conclure vous êtes
à l'aise au sein du front de gauche
aujourd'hui le parti communiste il ya eu
des discussions autour de ça avec
pendant les législatives
pendant les dernières élections
aujourd'hui nous il n'y a pas de y'a pas
de problème au sein du front de gauche
c'est pareil on n'est pas toujours
d'accord sur tout si on traite tous dans
le même parti le front de gauche c'est
un rassemblement de partis mais surtout
de citoyens c'est pas un cartel c'est
pas la gauche plurielle de la gauche
c'est le parti communiste le parti de
gauche la gauche unitaire ensemble
d'autres partis mais c'est surtout des
milliers de citoyens qui sont avec nous
à nos côtés qui se battent à nos côtés
donc oui des fois on se frotte un peu
parce que c'est la démocratie il me ya
aucun problème au sein du front de
gauche après deux candidatures
dissidentes ou du front de gauche nulle
part ni dans le département on n'y a pas
de souci on reste front de gauche c'est
notre démarche politique merci je vous
lis arabe aura donc les élections
départementales premier tour 22 mars
second tour 29 mars merci à vous un tout
autre de sujets à présent le concours
d'enfants bébé cadum qui vient de fêter
à paris ses 90 ans parmi les prétendants
cette année une petite fille de 2 ans et
demi qui est installé à guyancourt avec
ses parents nous les avons suivis
piscine géante à boules stand maquillage
et bonbons à volonté même pour les
adultes la marque bébé cadum vient de
célébrer les 90 ans de son célèbre
concours à paris ce mercredi 11
finalistes ont été désignées chaque mois
par les internautes sur le site
magicmaman.com et parmi eux inaya deux
ans et demi petite fille de lui en cours
et qui fait le bonheur de sa maman comme
le veut la formule consacrée on est
fiers parce que c'est pas mal hein quoi
agacer prestigieux c'est une grande
marque adam et c'est un honneur pour
nous de pouvoir en france ont représenté
cette marque voilà on est content c'est
une jeune expérience à vivre parce que
finalement on fait de belles rencontres
rencontrez pas maman partout en france
des moments de facebook voilà donc c'est
sympa inscrite à plusieurs reprises
depuis l'âge de 6 mois il n'a accédé
pour la première fois à la finale les
tenues pendant tout le mois entier on
devait voter sur internet etc et du coup
bah là c'est vraiment la grande finale
donc on est venu pour la sinne droit de
vivre douceur innocence 3 des critères
retenus pour désigner le lauréat
ambassadeur de la marque et même si ici
nous sommes bien loin des concours de
beauté et de minimis il reste toujours
une petite appréhension au moment du
verdict le bébé cadum de cette année et
name
c'est mérité pour naim je suis contente
sincèrement qu'elle ait gagné
inaya ne sera finalement pas élue bébé
cadum mais elle repartira avec de beaux
souvenirs pendant que la marque
capitalise sur son aspect familial quand
on a racheté cette marque on s'est rendu
compte qu'ils avaient cette élection du
bébé cadum
et qui à 90 ans cette année et on s'est
dit que ça allait être une formidable
opportunité pour d'abord célébrer les
valeurs familiales de cette marque
lequel on est très attaché et en même
temps de mettre en avant l'association
mécénat chirurgie cardiaque chaque année
depuis douze ans 80 mille euros sont
reversés à cette association qui fait
venir en france pour de lourdes
opérations des enfants malades
un portrait à présent kenji vannes a fui
la chine de mao elle s'est installée à
rambouillet à la fin des années 50 c'est
une fille de parents occidentalisée
comme elle les appelle elle se fait
connaître en tant que pianiste
compositeur mais aussi peintre c'est une
artiste complète une vie hors du commun
qui a décidé de rencontrer le
journaliste bernard delattre en
recueillant son témoignage un livre elle
qui vient de paraître aux éditions de
l'harmattan yolaine thorez et le diwan
chain d'ivana un parcours peu ordinaire
né à pékin elle se réfugie une première
fois avec sa famille à hong kong lorsque
la guerre sino-japonaise éclate en 1937
son père patron du plus grand quotidien
de pékin perte ou la famille fut la
chine de mao et s'enfuit ensuite à
shanghai à taïwan et à hong kong de
nouveau challenge ivan étudié au
conservatoire de musique et devient une
grande pianiste reconnu une vie digne
d'un roman que le journaliste bernard
delattre raconte dans ce livre en 1951
elle débarque en france à paris un jour
férié tout était fermé se souvient elle
j'ai cent des deux latins
valide gr j le ciel est gris
nez mieux sur noah
et le métro c'est noir aussi alors je
veux c'est dire
dans c'était bien qui restera pas croire
bras
finalement elle ne retournera pas dans
son pays devenu marxiste et s'installe
avec son mari à rambouillet à la fin des
années 50 dans leur jardin ils font
construire un édifice original qui lui
sert de salle de concert pour se
produire une construction connu dans la
ville est appelé par tous la pagode et
saint paul à c'est la forme
est de bagdad mais c'était pas et
baggott
cdc j'ai pas dit aux revues ya pas de
bouddha ya pas de prières
tout simple à gt challes
cancer l'opposition avec ses soeurs
restés en chine comme sympathisante des
maoïstes la séparation de ses parents ou
encore ces candidatures aux élections
présidentielles en france ce témoignage
cache d'autres secrets à découvrir au
fil des pages de l'ouvragé
c'est la fin de ce journal on se
retrouve demain vendredi pour l'actu du
jour et puis le résumé de la semaine
comme comme comme à chaque fois une très
bonne soirée sur téléphiles ce sera
notamment avec florane parfait pour un
nouveau numéro de fil échos